foreign
tonight concerns immigration it's the
reason I'm here well the reason I'm in
this country not the reason I exist the
reason for that should be obvious a tax
accountant a stork and voila here
I am specifically we're going to talk
about the situation on our Southern
border and I know what you're thinking
you're thinking finally someone is going
to address the Magnificent statue in El
Paso known as pile of gators fishing
what looks like a bunch of horny
reptiles engaging in a sloppy swamp orgy
but while that is certainly a situation
on the border it is sadly not the
situation which refers to what's going
on with migrants down there and if you
ask politicians on the right that
situation can best be summed up like
this our border is wide open and out of
control and Americans are dying because
of it the truth is that there is an
invasion happening at our Southern
border migrants are absolutely invading
this country our country is under attack
America is being invaded
no American is safe okay let's first
acknowledge the irony of cowardly
freaking out about migrants in front of
a song that reads Mr strong never before
has a nameplate felt so intensely
sarcastic but also setting aside the
blatant xenophobia there are the two of
you wearing matching outfits because it
sure feels like you met up at Men's
Warehouse made a b line for the
Caucasian collection picked out the
exact same suit and then wore it like
Tweedledum and tweedled deportation
the ride has been fear-mongering about
immigration even more than usual lately
and to be fair actually I don't have to
be fair them but to be fairer than
they actually deserve there is a lot
happening at the border right now the
number of Migrant encounters there which
was Rising before Biden came into office
reached a record high last year now that
has happened for a number of reasons
including that we're coming out of a
global pandemic and multiple countries
from Haiti to Venezuela to Ukraine are
in crisis right now so there's a high
number of people forced to flee their
homes plus some Asylum Seekers May
understandably have been encouraged by
Biden's rhetoric on the campaign Trail
which was notably different than his
opponent look I can't only imagine what
it's like to see someone in your family
deported that's right I can only imagine
what that's like and I've to me it's all
about family beginning middle and end
it's about family that's not going to
happen in my Administration the idea you
can't even seek Asylum ons American soil
can't even seek asylum in American soil
when did that happen Trump
it's wrong you're going to change that
yes I am yeah it's all about family
beginning middle and end whatever the
that means a pretty empty phrase
from a presidential candidate but to be
honest a pretty good tagline for fast
10. it's only mildly less comprehensible
than the end of the road begins
at the time that promise sounded good it
is worth remembering that even if Biden
wasn't your favorite candidate even if
he was your least favorite candidate
after four years of trump that was
pretty refreshing it's like wandering
through the Sahara Desert for four years
and all of a sudden seeing a Panera I
mean it's not necessarily Paradise in
its own right but compared with what you
just went through you would kill for an
Asiago turkey sandwich in the lemonade
no question
promises like that are why we cited
Biden's potential to undo Trump's damage
on immigration as a key reason to vote
for him just a week before the election
now did we make the difference who can
say nurses are the real heroes
unfortunately no when it comes to the
southern border Biden has disappointed
in a lot of ways but it is not because
he's opened up the country to an
invasion it's actually in many ways the
opposite many migrants including Asylum
Seekers are finding it impossible to
access this country through our ports of
entry and the conditions that they're
facing are dire in many border cities
shelters and detention centers are
reportedly near capacity with the
director of one of them saying every day
I turn away at least 10 families with
children and just last month at least 40
people died when a Migrant Center caught
fire and frustratingly a lot of this has
been exacerbated by U.S policies that
are well within Biden's power to remedy
and yet he hasn't and that is basically
what our story is about tonight it's
about what Biden promised to do what he
has and hasn't done and how his latest
efforts to fix things might actually
make them worse and first let's
acknowledge it is impossible to assess
what Biden has done at the border
without looking at what he inherited
Trump campaigned on high octane
xenophobia and his policies reflected
that from large-scale family separation
to attacking DACA to his so-called
remain in Mexico policy which led to
massive encampments of would-be Asylum
Seekers south of the board and Trump
approached all of it with his signature
clarity the immigration laws are
horrible we're doing an incredible job
we're doing a record-breaking job but we
have bad laws you know when you have bad
laws you can do good but you can do a
lot better if you had good laws okay I
mean that is total gibberish but if you
look at what he's saying closely there
you'll find it's also and this is true a
haiku
I'm I'm kidding it absolutely isn't but
wouldn't it be great if it was if that
buffoon was capable of accidental Beauty
but it's not and he isn't so we're back
to square one now
to Biden's credit he created a task
force to reunify the separated families
he strengthened protections around
Docker and he suspended the remain in
Mexico policy and yet there remained
huge numbers of people stuck just South
of the Border in camps that look an
awful lot like the ones that were there
during Trump and a significant reason
for that has to do with a policy called
title 42 which allows the U.S to kick
migrants out of the country with
shocking ease and we've talked about it
before but just as a refresher it's not
actually an immigration law at all it is
an Arcane Public Health order aimed at
preventing the spread of communicable
diseases the Trump Administration
implemented it in March of 2020 invoking
it as a safety precaution intended to
prevent covid-19 from spreading through
border patrol stations but the truth is
long before covid its use had been
floated by Stephen Miller a child's
answer to the prompt draw Squidward from
memory in fact the invocation of title
42 was referred to as a Stephen Miller
special he was all over that a sentence
I truly hope no one has to speak or hear
ever again and Miller has bragged about
title 42's sweeping powers
the principle of it is very simple which
is that during a pandemic if you come
into this country your very presence
here if you enter unlawfully
is a threat to our Public Health
full stop you go home okay first I'm
you played the sound of Stephen Miller's
voice in a Maternity Ward a newborn
infant would instinctively say despite
not having any knowledge of the English
language
shut the up
because that threat to our public
United with the CDC one former Health
official said that they were effectively
forced to implement it adding it was
either do it or get fired in fact the
CDC scientist said there was no evidence
title 42 would actually slow the spread
of coronavirus but the reason Trump
seized on it is pretty obvious under
normal circumstances migrants have the
legal right to ask for Asylum no matter
where they cross the border but like in
cell Caillou said title 42 gave the
government the power to rapidly expel
any migrant without giving them an
opportunity to make a case for staying
in the country legally including to seek
Asylum and you would hope that upon
taking office Biden would move as fast
as possible to get rid of it but instead
his administration has been all over the
place just a few months into his
presidency his Secretary of Homeland
Security sent this message to potential
migrants the message is quite clear do
not come
the border is closed the border is
secure
we are expelling our families we are
expelling single adults under
um these cdc's Authority Under title 42
of the United States code because we are
in the midst of the pandemic and that is
a public health imperative except it
wasn't a public health imperative and
everyone knew it and look if you're
going to Parrot Trump's harmful talking
points at least throw in some of the
funny ones as well every time you do a
press conference to bolster some
xenophobic policy like title 42
you also have to go off on attention
about how Robert Pattinson should have
dumped Kristen Stewart it is the least
that you can do
for months afterward the Biden
Administration let the policy stand and
even at one point defended it in court
then to be fair they did try to end it
only for a federal judge to block those
efforts with reporting of the time
indicating that the ruling was met with
a site of relief inside the White House
moreover by nationally expanded who
could be expelled to Mexico under title
42 because while the order initially
allowed the us to do that with migrants
from these four countries he chose to
broaden it first to include Venezuelan
migrants and later to those from Cuba
Haiti and Nicaragua and the
administration will point out and not
wrongly that they have issued
humanitarian exemptions to title 42 it's
estimated that around 187 000 migrants
were granted exemptions from May of last
year to just last month but not only is
that a action of those seeking Asylum
the Administration has been criticized
for a lack of clarity and consistency in
who is eligible and in general some have
argued that there's been a pretty
glaring discrepancy in who the country
has and hasn't decided to allow in
at a migrant shelter in Tijuana Mexico
claims of a double standard special
treatment for ukrainians fleeing the war
and being admitted to the U.S I love
that the government is helping them
because they've gone through a really
hard situation but that's not what
happens for people here exactly we
should all be treated the same the same
way how do you guys account for the
difference in the treatment between them
and you guys
racism yeah of course
to so many questions like why are some
people treated differently at the border
why did Roseanne Barr get fired and why
does your grandpa insist on pronouncing
Kamala the way that he does
and title 42 including Biden's expanded
use of it has functionally robbed people
of their basic right to make an asylum
case for themselves which can be
devastating just as this Honduran
migrant talk about getting all the way
to America with his family on the
presumption he'd be able to apply for
Asylum only to be taken into custody and
woken up one day with an unpleasant
surprise
one of us asked where are you taking us
is it true we're being deported they
said no we're not deporting you we're
taking you to a shelter and you can keep
going from there and that was a lie they
tricked us when we got off the bus we
saw the sign that said Tijuana Baja
California that's when we realized we'd
been sent back so you didn't realize
until you were already in Mexico right
once we were already here
look that is clearly not how immigration
policy should work under no
circumstances should people on a bus be
lied to about where it's going unless
that is it's a bachelorette party bus
and they're demanding to be taken to
another bar even though one of them
already threw up on a pigeon in that
case and that case alone you say sure
you swing by CVS for some Pedialyte and
you take them back to their Airbnb
and because many migrants can't return
to the country that they were fleeing
they wind up stuck on our Southern
border or trying repeatedly to get back
into the country often at their own
Peril more than 890 migrants died in
border crossings last year making it the
deadliest year since the US government
began tracking border crossing deaths
and for those stuck in Mexico The
Experience can be harrowing one group
found that since 2021 there have been
over 13 000 reports of murder torture
kidnapping rape and other violent
attacks on migrants and Asylum Seekers
blocked in or expelled to Mexico under
title 42. now the good news is title 42
may be about to expire and the reason
for that is when the broader covered
Public Health Emergency ends on May 11th
title 42 is expected to expire with it
the bad news though is that even with
over two years to plan Biden's new
proposed rule may not be much of an
improvement for one thing Asylum Seekers
will now be expected an appointment at a
Port of Entry through a new government
app that Biden proudly announced in
January if they're seeking Asylum they
can use an app on their cell phone
called
cbp1one cbp1one
let's just spell it out not the number
one oh well thanks for spelling it out
that helps a great deal this is that app
and as you can see it's icon apparently
features and I honestly don't know what
else this could be a border patrol agent
with a raging boner
beanie juice since January as a way for
people to request exemptions to title 42
and the early result
aren't great every morning at 9 00 a.m
women frantically try to refresh the
government app hoping to get an
appointment to enter the us we watch
with Karina brasada who runs the shelter
by 905 all the appointments
and hope were gone
it's Lottery with people's lives with
people's families with people's
livelihoods with people's well-being
that is horrible we clearly should not
be placing people's fate in the hands of
a smartphone app and don't get me wrong
apps can serve a lot of functions for
example this one is for messaging your
friends this one is for receiving Robo
calls this one is for seeing what your
mom is up to this one is for
accidentally turning it on muttering
and finally turning it off after a
minimum of three choice this one is for
watching democracy crumble while Cher
tweets the most baffling series of
emojis that you've ever seen and this
one is for looking at photos of pugs Who
Make a Better Living than you do the
point here is we use apps for many
purposes but reserving an appointment to
try and secure the safety of your family
probably shouldn't be one of them as of
right now only about 740 people per day
can get appointments through the app but
since there are obviously far more
people who need them a day's
appointments can run out within minutes
which is why some have dubbed the app
Asylum Ticketmaster a truly terrifying
combination of words and just take a
moment to appreciate quite how shitty of
a company Ticketmaster is people saw
vulnerable migrants being robbed of
their ability to seek assignment thought
hey you know what this reminds me of
Ticketmaster a company about concerts
what's more many Asylum Seekers have
outdated cell phones if they have them
at all that don't support the CBP one
app and often have limited or no access
to the internet and on top of all of
this it requires people to upload a
selfie and its facial recognition
technology has worked better for some
than for others even for digitally Savvy
migrants the experience has been a
challenge
it doesn't want to scan he doesn't want
to scan his face they say the app has
glitches and some even claim the facial
recognition feature malfunctions for
those with darker skin I get up to the
option to scan my face but it has to get
closer and closer but it doesn't do
anything and that's the problem that it
takes a long time to load and that's
where it fails so we try it again yeah
pretty bad at one shelter in Reynosa
they even had to install bright
Construction lights for people with
darker skin to shine on their faces so
the app would recognize them and I've
got to say given the history of
everything that's happened in this
country ever it is hard to think of
anything more on brand than a US
immigration app that scans your face and
says not white enough
and none of this is even getting into
some of the other issues with the app
like that it's told migrants to report
to border stations 1500 miles away and
has made it very difficult for families
to get appointments together and for
anyone considering trying to circumvent
this process by crossing the border
between ports of Entry to request Asylum
something that again is completely legal
under by this proposal you would be
presumed ineligible for Asylum unless
you've already applied for it and been
denied in any country that you've
already passed through and as many
pointed out that is eerily similar to a
trump era policy that made migrants
ineligible for Asylum if they pass
through a third country on route to the
U.S and didn't seek Asylum there first
that forced people into dangerous
situations and was completely
antithetical to the basic tenets of U.S
Asylum policy and that is something that
Biden himself definitely used to
understand given that remember he's the
guy who said this can't even seek asylum
in American soil
when did that happen oh oh I can answer
that for you Joe now it's in a rule that
you just proposed and I know there are a
lot of things that we would all like to
forget from 2020 like the word
cuomosexual or how everything was cake
for a while or how Gonzo my hair got I
look like I legally have to tell
everyone that I just moved into the
neighborhood but your outrage of the
treatment of Asylum Seekers shouldn't be
something you're just allowed to forget
so if and when title 42 expires next
month it seems that we're not going back
to the way that things were before Trump
because with Biden's new proposal we're
just entering a different phase of an
immigration dystopia particularly for
Asylum Seekers and a lot of people are
unhappy with it the U.N High commission
for refugees has said it's inconsistent
with the foundational principles of
international Refugee law and
recommended that the government refrain
from adopting it look it is pretty
obvious the title 42 was never a
functional or compassionate model of
immigration policy but neither is
funneling migrants to an app whose boner
icon actually makes sense now given just
how thoroughly it people
so what can we do well restoring the
right to Asylum would roll back at least
some of the harm that's been done here
but that is just the start we also have
to scale up capacity of our entire
immigration System including our
immigration courts which as we've talked
about on the show before are massively
overloaded they're currently estimated
to have a backlog of over 2 million
cases and beyond that it is critical
that we also expand other legal
non-asylum Pathways into this country
basically we badly need actual
immigration reform which means
congressional action but that hasn't
happened in decades and until it does
our immigration system will remain
fundamentally broken but that is no
excuse for making things even worse with
bad policy and shitty apps and I know
this can be hard to hear for some
Democrats who are reluctant to hear any
criticism of Biden they will point out
that Trump was absolutely worse on
immigration which he definitely was but
that is too low a bar
Biden should at the very least be held
accountable to the promises that he made
but the problem is when it comes to
Asylum seekers in particular you're
talking about a group of people for whom
those promises are among the easiest to
break
and the fact is migrants are going to
keep seeking asylum in this country as
they have every legal right to do and we
need to make a choice in whether we are
comfortable to continue leaving so many
of them in squalor and danger at the
border or whether we are willing to
finally fulfill our nation's promise of
offering them a safer more hopeful life
in a free country complete with the
single horniest pile of gators in the
entire world